we know as educators that when we enter
this industry that we're not coming in
for some six-figure salary we're not
coming in for some glorious lifestyle we
know that we are entering this industry
to give but it is extremely
heartbreaking to see the state of our
system and the state of our schools i
don't
love education enough to risk my life
for it
[Music]
teachers in the u.s have felt overworked
underpaid and under-appreciated for
decades it's been common to hear that
devotion to their students is really the
main thing that makes their jobs worth
it i started teaching because my
educational experience wasn't one where
i felt seen or heard i wanted to be the
teacher that i wish i had had in my own
primary and secondary education it is
such a passion of mine to be able to
introduce someone to a talent that they
may not have known that they had and
being able to do that for students and
their families and be able to not only
build but nurture relationships that
already existed has definitely been my
favorite part of that role and any other
teaching role that i've had that
devotion to students might not be enough
to motivate teachers anymore contentious
political issues about things like gun
violence critical race theory
and lgbtq rights are trickling down into
classrooms it's a delicate environment
for teachers to navigate and not
something they necessarily have the
tools for
i know that when i started teaching
arizona the state where i was licensed
was going through an ethnic studies ban
and that was the first red flag for me
but it was also my first year teaching
so i figured you know
it's going everything's going to change
it's going to be wonderful i entered
with bright-eyed and bushy-tailed going
to change the world but unfortunately as
the years have passed we've also seen
very difficult political and social
situations happening well i know that
families want the power and the space to
educate their children the way that they
would like but in an academic space i
also have an opportunity and a duty to
tell students the black and white of
what's happening in the world so that
they can critically think frustrations
are heightened and teachers are walking
out by the hundreds of thousands
linkedin calculated that teachers had
quit in june at a 40 higher rate than in
june last year and a gallup poll in
february showed that k-12 educators were
the most burned out segment of the u.s
labor force
i think as educators we're in a
privileged place where we have the
ability to influence another person's
experience change the way they use
something just by the way we present it
to them know that in my personal
experience just having a bad morning or
not having enough sleep the night before
can instantly change the way that i
present a lesson which is definitely
going to impact the experience that
students have when they're receiving
content and making sense of new
information
when we are burnt out we're putting
ourselves on the back burner we're not
prioritizing our experience and it makes
it much more difficult to prioritize
anyone else's experience i can tell that
kids don't like school anymore because
they perceive it as a place that's
unsafe a place that they're not going to
be respected for who they are a place
where their bodies are in danger and i
can absolutely relate to all of those
things especially as a black woman in
schools and in the education system i
think i go from
at times like the class pet in my
workplace to
the word place threat there's no really
like middle ground a lack of teachers
could have serious consequences on a
generation of kids it also reflects an
ongoing battle for gender equality in
the workforce and highlights how the us
values female driven industries like
teaching or nursing and as women abandon
teaching roles in search of a better job
the situation is set to worsen
i'm leaving teaching because it's no
longer a space where i feel like i can
do my job freely
it's heartbreaking and scary to me
because i know that the classroom is a
very powerful place to be right now in
2022 i moved to merida mexico which is a
sister city to my hometown new orleans
louisiana i specifically chose mexico
because mexico is a place where i can
continue to learn and grow the labor
that women of color give has never been
compensated properly so i want to be the
person in my line that breaks that curse
so that our creativity is seen and
valued for what it is and it's
compensated accurately because we have
put in everything that we have a lot of
us
and it's not okay that we're leaving an
industry without much but what we can
leave with is knowing that our impact
has done something wonderful for the
world
and that all of that impact is going to
come back to us a hundred fold as long
as we continue to take care of ourselves
you